so first of all welcome to all of you
I'm sorry that we're a little delayed
but we're really fortunate um that the
director was able to with the
commissioner participate in an event
with our uh state with our Senator our
mayor or Governor at Fair Haven uh with
the groundbreaking of the new building
at the ver Haven Community Health Center
I'm Hoe foran from the Department of
radiology uh and on behalf of the
Department of radiology and the School
of Public Health I really want to
welcome all of you and appreciate your
patience uh we have a great EV event
ahead of you um this is a collaboration
between the department of radiology and
the Bora foran lecture uh as well as the
El School of Public Health the Deans
lecture series uh this could not have
happened without the sincere and
complete support of of both of those
entities and at this time there's a
million people I'd like to thank but for
the most part I want to thank our
speakers today and I'll do so uh now um
uh I'm going to hand it over in a minute
to our commissioner to introduce our
speakers I'm also grateful to to our
Dean Megan rany I'm grateful to Mandy
Cohen who is AR yel Lum who committed to
this event seven months ago and we
thought it would be a few little simple
small events uh and then things
intervened I'm also convinced that she
uh and our other guests have helped us
avoid a government shutdown because
otherwise we couldn't have done this um
uh also thankful the Solomon Center at
the Y Law School uh under Abby Gluck and
the Yale medical Council uh with
leadership from Wilton Sun have been
really instrumental in making us be able
to pull this event off I can't uh thank
all the CDC staff but I do want to
particularly thank Ursula shell uh for
her work um in collaborating on this
event so Dr Manisha Jani who will soon
take the microphone and introduce our
speakers is a Yale faculty member on
leave uh having taken on the enormous
responsibility of commissioner of the
Connecticut Department of Public Health
a position that she has held over over
these last two years including helping
us steer through the end of the pandemic
Dr utani is a world-renowned infectious
disease clinician and scholar and has
been a forceful ad advocate for the
ideal of healthc care as a human right
uh her work is infused with a commitment
to Health Equity as she helps us tackle
some of the greatest public health
challenges of Our Lives she's graduate
of pen Cornell and trained partly at
Yale before joining our faculty uh I
will turn it over to her and I want to
just thank everybody in advance thank
you very much for doing
this
thank you very much for that
introduction Dr Forman and it's a great
honor to be back at Yale as always and
to be here with these esteemed speakers
here today so I want to introduce our
two speakers our first is Dr Mandy Cohen
who is the director of The Centers for
Disease Control and prevention and the
administrator of the agency for toxic
substances and disease registry she's
one of the nation's top health Leaders
with experience leading large and
complex organizations and a proven track
record protecting Americans health and
safety Dr Cohen received her bachelor's
degree from Cornell her doctor of
medicine from right here Yale School of
Medicine great to welcome her
back I'm sure that's when she'd
befriended Howie and um you know her
Master's in public health from the
Harvard School of Public Health she
trained in Internal Medicine at
Massachusetts General Hospital Dr Cohen
led the North Carolina Department of
Health and Human Services where she was
lauded for her outstanding leadership
during the coid crisis focusing on
Equity data accountability and
transparent communication she also
transformed the North Carolina Medicaid
Program through the state's Medicade
expansion and her focus on whole person
Health with the launch of the country's
first Statewide coordination platform
ncare 360 prior to joining CDC Dr Cohen
served as the executive VI pres VI vice
president at alidade the CEO of alidade
Care Solutions and Dr Cohen was involved
in many aspects of the Affordable Care
Act policy development and
implementation during her time serving
as Chief Operating Officer and Chief of
Staff of the centers for Medicare and
Medicaid services as well as acting
director of the center for Consumer
information and insurance oversight it's
with this outstanding background that we
are so fortunate to have her now leading
the
CDC and now to Dr Megan Rainey who is
the dean of the Yale School of Public
Health and the cea Winslow professor of
Public Health she's an Emergency
Physician researcher and National
advocate for Innovative approaches to
Public Health Dr Ry earned her
bachelor's degree from Harvard her
medical doctorate from Colombia and her
master's degree in public health from
Brown she completed her residency in
emergency medicine and fellowship in
injury prevention research at Brown
University and she was previously a
Peace Corp volunteer prior to arriving
at Yale Dr Ry served as Deputy Dean at
the Brown University School of Public
Health the Warren Alpert endowed
professor of emergency medicine at
Albert Medical School of Brown
University and was the founding director
of the brown Lifespan Center for digital
Health Dr ry's research focuses on
developing testing and disseminating
digital Health interventions to prevent
violence and related behavioral health
problems such as well as on the coid
related risk reduction she's held
multiple National leadership roles
including co-founding and Senior
strategic adviser for the American
foundation for firearm injury reduction
in medicine at the Aspen Institute a
nonprofit committed to ending the gun
violence epidemic through a nonpartisan
public health approach and being
co-founder of get us PPE a startup
nonprofit that delivered Don and donated
and delivered PPE to those who needed it
most she is an elected member of the
National Academy of Medicine it's really
an honor to have them both here today
I'd like to say as all of us all three
of us being mother of two women as women
being mothers of two children
each got t t t on my words but you know
it's really remarkable to see these
women in leadership with this
outstanding background and we are so
excited to hear their conversation today
thank you thank you Dr
Jan
so thank you for joining us today I do
want to apologize again for the wait
thank you for your patience great things
come to those who wait um and thank you
Dr Cohen for joining us all the way from
Atlanta in my conversations with faculty
staff and students I know how much so
many of you have been looking forward to
this day I know there are many others
who are unable to attend in person but
are looking forward to watching the
recording on zoom and we're grateful for
your coming back to New Haven a place
that you once called home so as you all
know I launched the leaders in public
health series as one of the first event
series of my deanship here at Yale
School of Public Health I like so many
of you in the audience believe deeply in
the power of extraordinary Public Health
leaders and I'm committed to Bringing
these leaders thinkers and doers here to
Yale to share with us a little bit about
their career path Lessons Learned and
providing inspiration for those
particularly students who are going to
go out and be change makers themselves
as we Pioneer together a new era of the
Yale School of Public Health's
Independence we'll continue to have
speakers and collaborators that are
doing work centered around inclusion and
Community Innovation and
Entrepreneurship communication and of
course datadriven leadership today's
event with Mandy is only the second of
what I hope will be a long series of
bringing our community together across
the School of Public Health the school
of medicine and the rest of
Campus before we get started I do have a
little surprise those who came to my
last Dean lecture will have a heads up I
want you to look under your seat eight
lucky people have a small momento to
remember this
event there are some empty seats so uh
take a look that is so
opra who got
them got them show us your show us show
us your the little
swag go gotot some mugs in the back down
here
excellent so congratulations to you A
Memory of Dr Cohen's
visit by so without further Ado I'm
gonna move us into the discussion Dr
Cohen it is such a privilege and an
honor to have you here we're honor you
we got to share the stage sometimes over
the course of the co 19 pandemic I've
long been an admirer and an acquaintance
and I'm just really thrilled to have you
here joining us today thank you so I'm
goingon to start at the beginning not
going back to the beginning of your time
here at Yale but rather the beginning of
your time as uh North Carolina Secretary
of
DHHS I call that out because as Dr duani
can no doubt attest there are some
unique things that you learn in public
health as the head of a state health
agency wondered if you'd mind sharing
with our esteemed group of students
faculty and staff uh how your
understanding of Public Health and the
role of that intersection of government
private sector and nonprofits
over your tenure as secretary sure well
first before I can you all hear me um
before I dive in I just I do want to say
thanks for having me back it's wonderful
to be back in New Haven and it's been a
wonderful day of being at the Fair Haven
uh clinic and seeing them do a
groundbreaking and they're expanding
what they're doing um and you know I
think that my education here at Yale was
really pivotal for for me it allowed me
as a student to to think big and it was
the first time where folks said um it's
okay to to think about how do we want
the world to be different and how are
you going to fit into that space um as a
first year medical student Yale um
supported us to go over to South Africa
a bunch of of students and actually get
hands-on experience in global Health
working on the HIV uh crisis at the time
and you know it was just the start of a
journey thinking about um where do I fit
in um to all of that and I've been
incredibly lucky um to have taken I'm
I'm I'm grateful to have taken some
risks actually early in my career to say
I want to think about leading in the
public public sector space and
then sometimes you also get lucky I was
also in the right place at the right
time with the Affordable Care Act
getting passed um frankly I was in the
right place when when CMS had entered a
crisis when healthcare.gov didn't turn
on you might not you all might be too
young to remember in 2013 that crisis um
but all of these were incredibly
formative so that when I came to North
Carolina um in 2017 and I lived there
for five years I was brand new to North
Carolina I'm from New York originally um
and it was um you know North Carolina is
in a remarkable place and now my my
family continues to live there and now
I'm I'm from North Carolina now um after
you go through leading through a crisis
like coid um you you bond with the the
state but it is in I loved being there
but it was um it was a different role
going to lead at the state um at the
state level than the work I had done at
the federal government at the state
level you both get to build much more
authentic relationships you see the
problems um up close and personal in a
different way and um North Carolina is a
a challenging place to do work we I
worked for a Democratic governor we had
a republican super majority in um our
legislature so a divided government um
we were um were very um have a very St
divide Urban rural in in North Carolina
and so it was it was a really
interesting place to work but also I
went there to be Secretary of Health and
Human Services so I thought that was an
exciting challenge because it wasn't
just the director of Public Health or
the head of Medicaid or the head of
Mental Health I got to think about
knitting together all of those Health
and Human Services in service of health
and we really kept that as our North
Star really how can we deliver health
for the people of North Carolina um so
as I think about public health I think
that's what we're trying to do right is
think about populations and how do we
make them healthier and what what that
taught me was you cannot do that alone
from public health I think if I had
tried to to just do that from the perch
of Public Health without having the
benefit of thinking about the levers of
payment through Medicaid or the service
delivery in mental health or the social
services that we had there we couldn't
have put together that comprehensive
view of trying to drive towards health
so I felt pretty lucky that before the
pandemic I had three years of thinking
about how do we buy Health at a 20
billion dollar a year budget which I
will say is a bigger than the CDC budget
to big yes we get not kidding sadly
we'll get to that um right so a pretty
large budget when you think about all of
those comprehensive services and when
you ask that question of each and every
one of those levers from Social Services
to mental health to Public Health to
medicate to say how do we deliver and
buy health for this state it was pretty
powerful and so I love being able to
bring together those those l so when I
think about what did I learn about
public health it's a team sport and now
being able to then take that what we
were doing in terms of building towards
health and then take that into the
crisis of the pandemic um was really
important because that means when we
went into the pandemic we were thinking
about whole person Health in our
response from day one um and I was so
lucky to work for I think the best
governor in the country Roy Cooper um he
is just I could not have asked for a
better um boss um and partner in in that
response work and he called out right
from the beginning that trust was going
to be the most important thing that we
could focus on as we go into the crisis
how do we build trust and how do we
maintain trust with the people of North
Carolina and that's really um has shaped
me as I think about public health right
if we want the world to be different if
we want the world to be healthier it
always for me comes back time and time
again to trust and Trust yes is a
feeling but well I'm sure we'll get into
it but trust is a tactical plan um that
you have to execute on every single day
and that's a lot of what I learned about
leading through a Public Health crisis
at the state level um and certainly um a
lot of what I bring to to the CDC work
as um I'm three three months in now I I
love that the idea of trust being a
tactical plan you and I were just
talking about kind of the challenge of
so much of Public Health is thinking
about you know who are the Community
Partners how do we the problems how do
we describe accurately the breadth depth
and hotspots but then you have to have a
plan for what to do afterwards and
that's the other side of Public Health
that we so often don't talk about but
that I think is one of the special
sauces of certainly the ysm ysph
collaboration the collaboration of ysph
with our School of Management here um
and and thanks to Howie as well the
combination that that collaboration
between the med school and the School of
Management in terms of I'm going to go
on that trust theme um you know we all
cheered you on when you got the
directorship of the CDC it's just such
an incredible honor and I can't imagine
anyone better in this country to lead
the organization I know that recreating
trust has been a lynchpin of what you've
been talking about you wrote uh recent
editorial in the New York Times trying
to recreate trust in vaccines and
talking about how you were getting
yourself as well as your children
vaccinated I would love to for you to
share a little bit about how you think
about that work within the CDC as well
as some of your other hopes and dreams
um for your directorship at the CDC sure
I feel like I got a master class in
thinking about trust like I said working
for for governor Cooper and leading
through the coid crisis and what I took
away from that around the Tactical plan
for trust is really three buckets of of
of work the first is
transparency the second is Simplicity in
operations and I'll get to that or or
great execution and the third is
relation ships um so on the first is
transparency I think the the critical
Lynch pin of Public Health is to bring
visibility data and evidence to trying
to solve how we protect Health whether
it's identifying and responding to a
respiratory virus or our first uh cases
of domestically acquired malaria which
we had this year um in TW first in 20
years or it's understanding overdoses
from different types of fenyl or zyline
right having that data that transparency
um is critical to building trust so
transparency for us was absolutely
fundamental and what what's hard as uh
about transparency is science is
constantly evolving as we know we are
learning more things so it's really
critical to be able to say this is what
I know this is what I don't know and
importantly this is what I'm working on
to to know and I'll come back to you and
you can trust that this this public
health is not a black box um and I can't
tell you still um I was just with a
round table of reporters yesterday who
said this public Health's a black box to
us help us understand it better we want
to be your Champions but we don't
understand it let us in all right so
transparency I think builds trust and in
North Carolina leading through the coid
crisis we did a press conference every
day at two o'clock for six months and
then we did it every other day for
another six months and then we did it
three times a week or two times a week
for that right we did 170 press
conferences um I never thought I'd be
that person pointing to charts and
graphs on a on television every day but
but that transparency that that being
there willing to take questions was
really really important and public
health needs to both I think have simple
and clear messages transparency in its
data um as we're doing work okay that's
one then second and this is I really
feel strongly about in in North Carolina
I was not only the person who was
helping the public understand the
science and the data for why we were
making certain decisions I was also
responsible for the execution or the
operations of the response were there
tests in my community was there PPE for
folks was their vaccine when you said it
was going to be there right the
execution because we can talk and help
people understand it but if they go and
and and try to get a vaccine and they've
taken an hour off of work and their
appointment got cancelled we've missed
an opportunity and we can study vaccines
and their effectiveness but if they sit
on the Shelf they're not effective and
message is part of that Communications
that's simple and trusted but it's also
the operations and the execution and for
me I'm an operator you heard I was Chief
Operating Officer at at CMS the largest
payer in in the country and so I I
really feel like operations and I want I
want Public Health to make sure that
they feel accountable and ownership over
those operations because we can't make
folks and help folks protect themselves
if we both don't get the operations
right and then the third is
relationships we we're all humans at the
end of the day and it is remarkable
about how sometimes we forget that and
sitting down with folks and building
relationships which takes time and I
will say the power of showing up cannot
be um understated um we spent a lot of
time showing up in communities that were
historically marginalized showing up and
listening um was so important to trust
building to relationship building I was
lucky to have had three years of
relationship building across the aisle
before we went into the crisis and that
was really important um so that we had a
foundation um but we had to nurture that
Foundation through the crisis and it's
why we had 99% of our seniors got
vaccinated in North Carolina North
Carolina extraordinary voted to elect
Donald Trump twice um right so it
doesn't have to be partisan no um I
think that they we tried to show a way
where um where we could come together we
had all four of the de two Democratic
and two of our top Republican leaders
all four of them did a vaccine video for
us saying get vaccinated right in North
Carolina so we got to that place because
of relationships but also because of
transparency and good execution and
answering questions but that
relationship pce is critical and that's
that's a Roy Cooper taught me that for
sure how lucky you are I will say having
worked having spent 20 years in in Rhode
Island where Gina rundo was our most
recent Governor she's extraordinary it
is amazing to watch these folks that
know how to get things done and I will
say you are one of them who I have
enjoyed watching get things done so you
alluded in that answer to two things um
that I know know are have both been
longtime fosi of your career but also
are key to your work at CDC one is
around data and accuracy of data and
accurate capture of demographics so that
we can address equity and pay attention
to the historically marginalized
communities that are experiencing
disproportionate burden of disease the
other is around community and I think
back to your work at doctors for America
um as an Exemplar I would love to hear
your Reflections on either or both of
those thinking about both kind of that
data Equity issue how you I mean really
to me what you did in North Carolina
with getting demographic data um
accurately measured was just
transformative um how you're thinking
about that on a national level and then
how you you take those lessons from DFA
uh forwards well first I'm a data girl
um and so I think that data is the
oxygen that powers our work particularly
in public health if you can't see
problems you can't solve problems um we
know that there are disparities or
system but until you get that accurate
data there's a lot of hand waving of H
you know that's not my patient that's
not my right um so that clear crisp data
that changes action is really necessary
um so let me talk about what we did in
in North Carolina well we we said Equity
was at the center of what we were doing
and so we it was just unacceptable to us
to not be able to stratify every piece
of data that we had by race and
ethnicity um we did it for gender and
age too and so you could log a vaccine
in North Carolina without um without
race and ethnicity and we had 99%
completion on our race and ethnicity
data um we won won awards for that very
proud of that work and people fought us
on it said oh patients don't want to
answer that or our it'll be too slow for
our systems we managed through it right
we we came up with a bunch of Technology
Solutions but patients want to answer
that question or frankly why are they
answering that question it's in the EHR
already guys let's pull it out right so
it was how do we think about common
sense solutions to make that possible
but then we have to use the data right I
think a lot of times frankly in public
health I love I love you all but
parsimony Parson is not always our
strong suit in we just one more piece of
day one more question one more piece of
data we all have to collect race and
ethnicity in the same way every time for
every program so we have apples to
Apple's comparison against across every
program it seems super basic but we
don't do it at the C DC right now guess
well you're also kind of not allowed to
do it right there's some data use
agreement issues I don't I don't think
we can get past that so I I don't like
to tolerate that right and so I'm always
a how do we find a way right but so this
is where I also um think we have to um
one um expect that but then we have to
use that data for Action right and so it
wasn't just the collecting of it then
we're just admiring the problem right
it's it's the changing action and what
was powerful about it is that when we
were responding to the the crisis on a
day-to-day basis we were looking at that
information and we said why why aren't
vaccines over there why are why is that
community at a lower rate that that
Latino community over there at a lower
rate let's deploy resources over there
or you pick up the phone and say did you
know did you know this is happening
right and so you have to make that
actionable and it's a self um self
reinforce yeah so when you actually
using it and people are like oh this is
so useful now I want to collect the data
no no questions asked so it's great last
thing I'll say on data though that we're
doing is in addition to standardization
on how we collect so it's it's most
useful um we have to all of us no matter
where we sit whether it's CDC or
Academia um or the health systems we
have to get away from the mindset of
this data is
mine there's a lot of I will well I've
I've done the hard work of collecting
this data and and cleaning up I get to
publish from it yeah I'm going to
publish my and and I I appreciate that
like but particularly I'm working on
with CDC and with our state Partners um
we have to move away from the data is
mind mindset data is a national security
asset right is how we are going to
protect this nation um as we go forward
and we have to find ways to be able to
share that data um across the board um
we did it for coid if we can do it for
coid we should do it across the board we
have to do it for coid and flu and RSV
let's start there so right now we have
great data sharing and visibility so if
you want to know what's happening with
coid in your backyard you can know it
but you don't know about flu you don't
know about RSV in the same way we're
change we're working to change that and
I'm working with our state Partners
right because to your point there are
different authorities and and such but
we have to move ourselves towards that
that that path and I'm I'm looking for a
coalition of the willing to go on down
that path um with me and then I'll work
with Congress um to show why with that
power what why that's so necessary um
and that's needing help from our health
systems as well so the data is mind
mindset has to go we need that data to
power Healthy Communities um and so we
need to move quickly in that in that
direction love that so I'm going to do
one more question and then I'm going to
open it up um Dr Jani I'm sure is both
ready to be a coalition of the willing
but also we're excited for her to
moderate questions so my last question
is a slightly more personal one knowing
that this is a room of staff faculty and
students who came here to be inspired
and to learn a little bit about your
journey it's kind of a question about if
you had the chance to go back in time or
you have the opportunity now to speak to
a bunch of aspiring leaders themselves
what do you wish you had learned what
are you thankful you learned what do you
encourage the folks in the room to
pursue um as future Public Health
leaders so two pieces of advice um that
I've been giving um for for a while now
some one which I think I followed and
one which I was disappointed I didn't so
I'll do the good the good first um is be
uncomfortable um I had this opportunity
my my career has some like now I can go
back and tell like this nice story about
here how it made sense but my career
like zigzagged a bit um in ter terms of
was this the right step for me and what
I realize now in hindsight is that
building differentiated kinds of skill
sets allowed me to open doors to
different kinds of opportunities so if I
had just taken jobs that were fit for a
doctor um I don't think I would have
been able to make the progress in my
career there were times where I was the
communications lead there was times
where um I was the data lead there were
times when when it was my clinical
expertise that mattered there was
sometimes it was my policy expertise
sometimes I was just needing to be a
good manager um and so building
different kinds of skill sets but that
does require you to step out of your
comfort zone um sometimes crisis pulls
you in that direction and I would say
sometimes crisis is an opportunity um so
think about moments of big change for me
like I said when healthcare.gov didn't
turn on that was a big crisis moment for
the organization I was with I got to
step out dramatically from where I was I
was doing physician payment models
pretty typical what you know what folks
would be thinking I went to work to run
the call run a call
center right so that was a hard
conversation to have with my mom when
she was like what are you doing running
a call center um right but and I was
uncomfortable I was like I don't know
anything about a call center but you
know what it was a fantastic learning
experience to dive into something I
didn't know think about leadership and
man management right and and that
allowed me to start opening my mind a
bit about skill building in different
ways so be
uncomfortable second the other part is
about asking great questions in whatever
environment you in and I feel like this
is where I fell down Looking Back Now I
think there were moments where I didn't
take advantage of opportunities to ask
questions of people I was around because
I wanted everyone to think I already
knew the answers
right everyone wants I can't imagine
anyone in this room feels that way right
you want to front and be like I got this
right and it I missed opportunities to
really understand things earlier in my
career when I should have I should have
understood them earlier if I just asked
good questions at the time and I am so I
I'm am always so enamored by Young
students who ask really good questions
I'm like damn I wish I could have asked
those kind kind of questions when I was
your age I would have been much smarter
sitting in this in the seat right now
sometimes I had to do all the wrong
things um and learn the lesson so ask
good questions trust me if you have a
question others have a question but it's
also the opportunity to learn right no
one expects you early in your career to
know all the things so please like ask
good questions don't feel like you have
to know all the answers and I would say
that in any job I would say the more I
do in leadership I the way I lead is not
sometimes sometimes you need to be a
director leader but most of the time I'm
going to the team to be like what should
we do what should we do here I will help
you do it and my job as a leader is to
break down barriers for you right if
this is the right thing to do I'm gonna
right if there's an authority problem
I'm gonna fix it right if there's
politics we need to get through how can
I help if we need to communicate what
can I do right but I'm going to go to
those folks to say what should I what
should I do and it is to this day the
the fact that I've been able to hone my
ability to ask good questions I think
that has helped me um further my career
I love that and what a beautiful segue
into a chancef for questions to be asked
so thank you thank you for sharing those
Mandy I think that's lovely and and I do
really want to kind of double click on
on the idea that careers are not
straight lines and so for those who are
sitting out in the audience wondering
what their next step is to to not
hesitate to take that risk and to not
feel like you have to have it all
figured out now I feel like particularly
for kind of our newer generation there's
this sense that need to know on the day
when you start your graduate program
what you're going to do next and I don't
maybe you knew you were going to do
internal medicine or public health but I
sure surprised myself yeah thank you Dr
Jani thank you both we want to have an
opportunity for people to be able to ask
questions there are microphone Rovers in
the room so if anybody has a question
feel free to raise your hand at this
time we have a few in the front
here
I Dean rany and Dr Cohen thank you so
much for being here I wanted to um get
your thoughts on online misinformation
and disinformation as a public health
threat um you know little teeny topic
very small yeah if you so I know as
early as as recent as last year DHS
tried to launch a disinformation
governance board and that ultimately
failed um and we know a lot of
disinformation is rooted in fear and
misinformation um so H what is the
appropriate strategy to neutralize it
right if there aren't any Financial
incentives or if the political
incentives aren't even there so what can
everyone do to combat that yes um I
think this is really important topic so
a couple of ways that I thought
about about this right so I think those
of us with the good information need to
drown out the bad information right it's
a flood the Zone approach um so that so
much good information is out there that
the misinformation is is is muted but
understand that in order for us to get
good information out we have to
understand how folks are consuming that
information and they're consuming it as
entertainment and we are not
entertaining I wish I was um right but
us you are um so let's let's just be
honest and I think we have to meet folks
where they are and think about different
ways to communicate the good information
so one we have to just do more of it
right if everyone here see some
misinformation and then tweets the right
information or sorry X um uh threads get
on threads folks yeah exactly so so
right right and we need to we can't you
are complicit if we just like let that
stand um so we need to flood the Zone
with the good information but we also
have to flood it with information that
feels engaging to folks um and I'm to be
honest like I think we're all still
figuring this out and how to do this
well how and and like I think the
government particularly has a lot of
challenges doing that for a lot of not
good reasons but some good reasons um
and so we're we need to figure out how
how to engage better um far too often
and I was saying this this morning to
the team at at the Fair Haven Clinic um
you know my the team at CDC I love them
they're so smart and they're they're
like I'm so proud I put some fantastic
information up on our
website I'm like oh boy I haven't gone
to a website for information I don't
know when right and I can't I I love
public and I go to right so that's not
going to be good and that's not good
enough we have to modernize the way we
communicate as a strategy related to
disinformation then there's a whole
regulatory architecture that we need to
think about I am 100% fully supportive
of free speech
but I think there's nothing about free
amplification that I that we need to
think about and so there there's
something there in the Middle where we
can we can everyone can say the things
they want to say but they don't all need
to be Amplified in a way and and there's
again but that's in the world of laws
and and and regulations that folks need
to really think about that's broader
than even just public health information
it's bigger than that um so what we can
do in health care and public health um
is to flood the Zone with good
information we can be engaging we can be
trusted um and yes people get their
information from social media but the
most trusted Folks at survey after
survey survey your doctor and your nurse
right the nurse at your church and your
own personal doctor so like every time
you're walking into a room with someone
you have an opportunity to influence
their lives the number one reason people
don't get vaccinated their doctor didn't
mention it at the visit didn't say it
was
important not because they thought it
was a the doctor didn't mention it they
would have mentioned it if it was
important but mention it right so every
we have to take every opportunity we
don't have I don't think we're ever
going to be quite as engaging online so
like let's take every opportunity in
person that we possibly
can we have a question in the front row
over
here and then we'll go to the one in the
back thank you for the opportunity and
my question is for both of you bar of
the answer may be that both of you are
here so uh we are aware that I assume
that all of us know the importance of
the relation between institutes such as
CDC with academic research institutes
like like Kel so uh if you can elaborate
more on this collaboration and
relationship like to inform the the the
decisions and the policies and also like
what would you do different to
strengthen such collaboration and
relationship thank you well obviously
the our academic partners are incredibly
important to to train the the future Le
the current and Future Leaders of uh of
Public Health so very important as we're
thinking about what are those skill set
that folks need to build but there's
also really important questions that get
answered in Academia and we saw frankly
during the
pandemic case number one of like um our
our academic Partners being trusted
voices um to share really good
information um and and so so critical
but it's also about prioritization
together and having a shared agenda on
what are we trying to accomplish I think
there's more work we need to do there
between public health and Academia what
are the things that CDC needs to
research and do what are the things that
Academia that CDC can't do that Academia
could do um in different ways I don't
think we have as much of a of a unified
shared agenda as we need to I think
that's that's on the the to-do list I'm
only a few you know we're both a couple
of months in yeah getting to it right
but we we need to do that because I
think there are certain things CBC needs
to stop doing um I think there are
certain things that Academia needs to
pick up to do but what right and but we
have to have that um collaboration back
and forth to be like okay if you got
this then we're gonna we're we're GNA
not and we'll go over there because
there's so many important things we all
need to do there's too much work in the
world right so I think there's more more
work we need to do
but over to you exactly what you just
said I think that we think of ourselves
we can think of ourselves as extenders
of each other's skill sets we do sit in
slightly different places within the
ecosystem of Public Health and health
care and so how do we work in
Partnership to do the things that maybe
CDC or our state and local Health
departments wish they could do but can't
they don't have the staff they don't
have the infrastructure maybe they don't
have the very specialized expertise and
then vice versa our partnership back CDC
and state and local Health Department
departments have an unbelievable
platform to disseminate to implement to
actually change policies and procedures
on the ground um and have an incredible
Workforce that is present in almost
every Community uh across the United
States and then if we look globally
certainly there are Partnerships there
as well and so knowing kind of how then
on our side the information gets shared
and made actionable is huge the last
part that I'll say that I see is an
existing source of partnership that we
can grow is around grants um around
support of not just research but also
implementation for those who aren't
aware CDC is a tremendous funer of not
just research but also on the ground uh
implementation work and I think that it
behooves us as academics to think about
how we can be better Partners in in that
space um as well but the shared agenda
is something that I'm excited to to work
on going forwards and I think we're
going to have a bunch of opportunities
to think a little differently as we move
into this new ecosystem of Public Health
and healthare about how we can amplify
and extend each other's
work question in the back I believe yeah
go ahead sure um Dr con so nice to have
you here thank you for coming uh my name
is nor alabi I'm a first year um at the
school of Public Health so my question
actually has two parts um first I'm just
wondering what are some of the
strategies adapted from coid that are
kind of being used to be implemented in
the future or the preparedness
pH for like any future pandemic um
second part is actually one that I'm
very interested in I'm just wondering if
there has been any initiatives or your
review on preparing um programming or
any other kind of part of initiatives to
address immigrant um health issues in
the United States um and what would that
look like in the upcoming years great so
on the first in terms of Lessons Learned
From Co they're so many so so many but I
I'll go back to some core ones which is
we need data infrastructure to see
issues and solve problems um I think we
uh my first effort as North Carolina
Secretary was an effort we called kill
the facts and that's because we were
getting lab data by facts uh uh when we
went into a historic pandemic so I had
250 people entering information into a
computer until we killed the facts but
right so we've built systems now
fantastic but we built them for coid but
there's some railroad tracks there right
so we've laid some tracks on how to
build pipes and and think about this and
so CDC is being funded for a huge data
monetization effort that's across CDC
it's to the states a lot of work being
done we have to get systems that talk to
each other across healthc care and
public health so a lot I mean absolutely
fundamentally have to do that if we want
to call this a public health system
data integration is like absolutely
fundamental then there is all of the
work related to how we recognize Public
Health as a team sport we saw how we
needed to bring in different folks and
clarifying roles and responsibilities in
peace time versus crisis time what are
the right roles and responsibilities for
the health delivery system I will say in
North Carolina our our major Hospital
systems were hugely important and and I
got give huge credit to them I would
convene the competitors right their
business competitors across our state
I'd convene them every Monday morning to
make sure that we were aligned and
executing um but that's not the the norm
right that's that's in crisis so how do
we think about rosm responsibility not
in crisis as well um and then the the
communication and Trust building you
can't build trust in a crisis you have
to be there throughout so the trust
building has to start now for a crisis
we may have 10 years from now right in
the community ities that we need to be
in so I heard an interesting point this
morning at Fair Haven that um you know
we're spending a lot of of effort on the
Mental Health crisis and they said you
know what more than the Mental Health
crisis we're actually seeing Dental
Health as one of the most significant
needs for the community here and I was
like oh well one oh that's so hard um
and but so important so like let's start
like let's listen as Leaders right to
that's how you build trust you listen to
what are the community's first top
priorities let's solve that so that in
five years if we have another crisis
hopefully not um that we've we're there
we're solving problems that matter to
the community so like we have like now
is where when we have to do the
preparation and in terms of um our um
immigrant communities what I I love
about public health and and I'm so proud
of CDC and only being there three months
I take no credit for this but it is
honestly the most Equity focused um
organization that I had have have been
part of and I'm very proud of the North
Carolina work but it was a lot of like
new work when I come to CDC and I see it
the equity work is embedded everywhere
in a great way and they think about
populations and um they are thinking
about um migrants and and their health
at all times and thinking about how do
we make sure we're understanding what
they need and and think about it so for
example I was just on the phone with
folks in in New York um who are seeing a
lot of um new immigrants and migrants um
that are are there and how can help them
with from an infectious disease place
but also from housing and things like
that so CDC like that's I give them ton
of credit um for doing incredible work
the resources are what is missing there
it's not the passion it's not the the
the strategy it's resources in order to
make sure that we can help all those
communities and if I can just jump in
really two things one is around the
migrants it is just to put a finer point
on that Partnerships um recently had a
lovely conversation uh with the head of
Health and Human Services in
Massachusetts it they're also struggling
with the same problem and it really is
the Partnerships that it's not all on
DHHS um helping to provide uh a a
livelihood and a life um to allow folks
to start to integrate so often right we
think about health as sitting off in
this bubble versus being part of this
much larger ecosystem of of issues and
things that help to create Health the
other thing is you were talking about
the data modernization initiative going
back to your question something that we
can do in Academia is to help tell the
story of why CDC matters and of why
their initiatives matter so I bring up
the data modernization initiative
anytime I talk to a policy maker CDC has
asked for 165 million more or less more
than that you you're going up you're
going up for Michelle's estimate okay
that's less than it cost to put Epic
into one hospital system yeah that's why
my number's bigger good uh but but just
to kind of put that in context people
don't think about it if you're talking
to policy makers they don't think about
data as coure to Public Health the way
that we do and so we have that chance to
tell the story we also have the chance
to tell the story of why CDC matters why
this work matters in those Community
relationships and to help create the
connections that then allow you to hear
that dental health is the primary
concern of the community that's being
treated at this major fqc in New Haven
so just as a an addition to to the
beautiful question that you asked
earlier and nor thank
you Dr Cohen we are killing the facts in
Connecticut we haven't quite killed
but your data monitorization efforts are
helping us get there okay we have I know
several other questions I saw okay right
here on front right thank you so much
thank you for being here uh I had a
question on behalf of a person I know
who's on dialysis and they were
wondering why it's not required for
healthcare workers to wear n95
respirators in healthcare settings
especially um when Decades of research
showed that respirators are more
effective than search called at
preventing Airborne diseases and uh with
like 60% of Co infections asymptomatic
and Hospital acquired infections four
times uh higher have a four times higher
risk of
mortality so great question so we have
different teams who um are are looking
at at some of these issues right now and
I think updating some of the guidance
right so I think you want to look at a
we look at a couple of factors when
thinking about it sure is an n95 going
to certainly filter out more things than
a surgical mask yes we know how those
work right if you have something that's
fit tested and and and the the different
material so but the question is what are
the things that you need to wear an n95
for and what are the things where
surgical barrier masks make make sense
and you want to look both at the way um
the infection is spread but also what is
the risk right so we spread you know a
lot of things that are are aiz but
they're different levels of risk um it
is it is good news in 2023 where we are
related to coid 97% of us have either
had it or have been vaccinated um by it
so we aren't in the same place we were
in 2020 when we had an entire population
that's never been exposed now I wouldn't
I have to be on brand for CDC director
I'm glad we got to this um our our our
immunity is going down the virus is
changing please all get your updated
coid vaccine even those of us who are I
I'm I'm I almost was saying I'm as young
as you I'm not I'm getting my vaccine
but please everyone at every age should
get it as well as your flu shut but my
point is is that that we have to think
about levels of risk for all of those
different kinds of diseases versus in
terms of what is the protection level
that we need um and so so those are the
kinds of research that the team goes
through we actually have an independent
advisory committee that is going through
some of that work um right now to
understand the data and what how do you
how do you map to um the right the right
protection because it's both how is it
how is it transmitted but also like what
is the risk to all all of the the
patients and we sort of need to balance
all all of those things great thank you
I know there are a few others uh right
behind the last person who
asked hi um thank you for being here I
this question is addressed to both of
you but it's based on something that Dr
Cohen said um you said earlier that
data is a national security asset and we
need to move away from a data is mind
mindset and so I was wondering whether
you think there's a place for the CDC or
just general US Health policy to maybe
require this data sharing um especially
in the realm of Public Health because
it's so important to just our General
Health in general for the whole uh
country yeah the short answer is yes so
I and I talk about it with Co with
members of Congress whenever I have a
conversation with them um now I
understand why um that we have to have a
balance here just like balance in the
last question I was talking about we
want to collect data to have that
visibility we need to protect privacy
absolutely I I think that is important
too A lot of the data that can be
actionable can be deidentified in the
way that we collect it um and and use it
and it still be actionable there are
some places where that shouldn't be true
um in terms of case identification but
those are the things we're trying to
work through with Congress and help them
understand deidentified data is what
we're really talking about as the asset
that we need to understand and respond
to threats and I think we're making some
progress there um but you know
unfortunately these modernized Data
Systems and all they're expensive also
just candidly data is a
um gives you uh Market power um in the
Health Care system and so you know there
there are different forces that pull
upon this so we're going to try to tell
the story of why we need um this data I
spent most of my career on the health
delivery side we have to do this in a
way that is not burdensome to the health
delivery system we we need to pull and
extract the data out of ehrs we cannot
ask for additional manual work for folks
so this is where my I'm wearing my CMS
hat um for for a second right their CMS
you know has a lot of mechanisms in
which we collect data already Public
Health needs to fit into that Mech ISM
so we need to make sure it's not
burdensome we need to make sure that
that the Privacy is protected but yes
additional authorities are absolutely
needed to keep the country safe and and
that gets to your Simplicity precept
around trust which is that we have to
make it really easy for people to gather
share and use data I will say that there
is actually uh any of you who have CDC
NIH or NSF funded grants know that we
are already expected to share data to
deposit whatever ever data we can in a
shared data repository um whether it's
quantitative or qualitative once you
have removed those markers of privacy I
also think to your point around that
that privacy and ethical question it's
why it's so important for us to think
about this being done not on an
individual basis but on an individual
locality basis but across States regions
and the country because what we often
find is that some of our smallest groups
their data gets suppressed over and over
so it limits our ability to look with
gran it to Mandy's earlier point about
data Equity at for example um uh native
Hawaiian and Pacific Islander
populations because in a given Locale
the numbers may be so small that then it
becomes identifiable so it's it's a way
to think about kind of improving Equity
as as well as data sharing um but I'm
I'm de this goes back to your work in
North Carolina you were so committed to
creating spaces where that even if
perhaps the full data set couldn't be
shared that the summaries of the data
could be um which which allows access in
in other ways and then I think helped
you to be a convenor um of data sources
yes and I was going to say I I love um
we have amazing scientists at the CDC
and they are are incredib they want
precision and sometimes that's not going
to be possible in the messy world that
we live in and so I'm thinking about
well if we can't collect everything what
what's half a loaf I'll take that to
start um so we're trying to get get to
that place okay we've got about six
minutes left so I'm going to try to take
two but let's take one question uh there
was one in the back there and then we'll
try to come back here to the front if we
can fit it in in the back hello oh hello
thank you for being here Dr Cohen I can
only imagine your busy schedule and
taking the time to be here for us is
very um gratitude instilling but thank
you my name is Lena Jones I a third year
in yell undergrad and I wanted to ask
about how as a woman of data you plan
for data's ethical use because I know
that there's this long history of data
being collected and intended for
wonderful purposes and then that its
actual application ends up harming the
communities that it was most intended to
serve yeah um great question this is
part of the you need to protect privacy
as we go right so a lot of times we can
do this do the data collection um
without making sure that we're
identifying any individual that's that's
um the first but I think this goes to
deep seated de decades upon decades
where the structural way in which we
both collect and use data there as we
know there is racism built into our
structures and so then when we take take
the even the way we collect data um
being have having disparities built into
it and then we try to use these new
tools like AI or our AR language models
like we perpetuate those uh disparities
so we have to really be thinking about
it proactively in the front end but
honestly when I hear your question it
always goes back to trust right is are
we having the conversation on the front
end and helping the community see is
like when we ask these questions and
we're collecting this data it's to help
come back to you to make sure that it's
better and actually deliver on that um
it's it's why knowing that Dental is the
most important issue here is really
powerful so we could be off collecting
data on coid vaccines but everyone's
like what really why aren't you
collecting data on what's going on
related to my oral health right and so I
think it's also having those trusting
conversations with folks and then also
making sure that you're always being
value ad and we have to check ourselves
in public health because I think we come
in with a lot of idealistic um thoughts
about what a community needs um and that
we really need to make sure we're taking
a beat to listen and here I'll just say
if this is an issue that interests you
check out data Haven which is a local
organization run by one of our yph
graduates Mark Abraham that does a
lovely job collecting sharing and
empowering communities to use um local
data around health so a lovely example
great yeah oh it's super cool it's super
cool okay we have time for one quick
last question right here in the front
please last question hi okay I will make
it quick uh hi I'm Rachel I'm a second
year at the Y School of Public Health I
actually work for the commissioner over
the summer so it's great to see you all
in person uh my question is what do you
see as the role of the CDC in advancing
whole person Health on a national scale
um and how will that dovetail the
localized State efforts already in
motion big question to end and well I'll
go back to where um I I started I
actually think public health is one
piece of that um and it has to be a team
sport um I think there's a lot of pieces
in public health but I'll go back to
like public health is not resourced to
to fulfill its current Mission which is
identifying and responding to threats um
and so it we do but there is a lot of
Public Health principles that I want to
map to all of the levers across
Healthcare and that's not just Health
delivery system as I said Social
Services has to be part of it education
has to be part of it Transportation has
to be part of it so this is a US
Government um approach and frankly got
to get the private sector Academia right
it's a team sport here um and that's you
know for me like that's the exciting
part is how do we knit these pieces
together what I'm trying to do at CDC is
make us the best collaborator we
absolutely possibly could be now I think
data is is the power behind that because
like that visualization but it's
building a muscle of collaboration is
different right how like candidly like
CDC does not have um right now someone
who owns engagement stakeholder
engagement um or we want to call it
something else but right but doesn't
have that function right but if we're
going to be the best collaborator and if
this is a team sport we absolutely have
to build that muscle differently so
those are the kinds of things I'm
working on at CDC but we have a lot to
offer in it of itself right with the the
data evidence and best practices so that
we can go to someone like CMS and be
like you know what you should be paying
for is X not y right or we can go to
samama and say you know what we we've
studied this best practice in suicide
prevention this is where you should put
your money and they do and we're doing
that right now so that we're trying to
model out those best um opportunities
collaboration make sure public health is
strong in what it can offer in terms of
data evidence best practices and then
that can but don't leave it there it has
to get to the to the folks who then
deliver the services so that they know
how to use the data evidence best
practices and so like making those
connection points is like very important
to me um and so we're going to be doing
a lot of that at the CDC but we can't do
it alone and it'll be it'll be a team
sport and everyone's on on team health
so thank you well I cannot think of
anyone better to exemplify leadership in
public health than Dr Cohen I cannot
thank you enough on behalf of all of us
we do have a small so a thank you to
Mandy thank you so I want to thank
Claire who if those don't know her is
the brains and heart who works with
Howie and allows him to have brains and
heart as well not that he didn't have
them before but thank you CLA your help
and and we have a small gift bag for you
as well as for Dr Jani as a thank you to
both of you also exemplifying leadership
in public health on behalf of our state
okay again just a very warm thank you to
both of them for their presence
leadership and
Grace thank you all for coming and for
this inspirational conversation today
thank you
for